hello and welcome to the seventh Python
game development with PI game and
specifically Python 3 tutorial video in
the last video we made these objects
appear they come at us they start at
random places and you know they move and
went on and in this video what we want
to do is we want to have something
actually happen when we crash into these
little objects because our objective
here is to avoid the objects so we want
to have some sort of handling for if we
happen to run into them so close out of
this and we'll get started so in our
script again just like we have you know
these this group of logic here we're
going to keep building on this group of
logics so we'll come down to this point
and we'll create some logic now this
one's a little more challenging than it
did the left side of the car across or
did the right side of the car cross or
did the top of the object cross over the
bottom this one a few things have to be
the case and I think the best way to
illustrate this is by black drawing it
and paint or something so here's paint
and we'll just say you know this is our
car and we'll make our car green on the
inside just to differentiate between the
box and then we have a box and the box
let's do this you know you've got a box
and as the box comes down in order we
have to ask a few questions so if the
box is here um this is like this layer
here so we can use a line you know
there's cross over here but there's not
cross over here so it's so the box that
didn't hit so um the why is lower than
the wine it's crossing over the Y of our
object whatever it is so our main
character which is the race car it's
crossing over but the x's aren't crossed
over so we don't have a
collision here conversely we could have
this right and we are actually within
both bounds like both walls so we're
within here but we're not within the Y X
so we're within the X's but we're not
within the wine at the same time we
can't ask if we're in both X's but we
have to ask if we're in one of the X's
so for example um let's see here there
we go
anyway this would be a collision right
and not because you know we're not in
the way of you know this one obviously
they're not lined up but this one is the
collision right so we have to check
whether it's hitting this one or it's
hitting this one and it's also got to be
hitting the Y so one of the sides and
the Y has to be hit so that's the kind
of logic that we have to build so now to
say that so now we come over here and so
now we're going to start asking some
questions for our logic so the first
thing we want to ask is if if the if the
tip of the car is higher um which means
less than really in it with Y right so
we're asking if Y if the X is if the
cars Y position is higher or has a less
lesser Y value than the Y of the Box the
bottom of the box we might have a
collision there so we'll say if Y is
less than thing underscore start Y now I
know we called this variable things
start Y but we only did that just at the
very beginning but now things start Y is
like the position it starts from before
it gets modified basically but anyway
things start Y twice thing underscore
height so things start why should we
close our our paint let me open up paint
again but things start Y if we had a box
right so here's our box things start
wise up here it's at
King if this is lower than a race car
which is here right but we actually want
to know if this is crossing over the
race car so if any point this is less
than the race car that's when we really
want to know if there's some crossover
going on
so in fact I'm going to keep this open
for now um so that's what we're asking
right now is if that if the bottom line
and really what we're asking is not if
we just if we didn't do the image height
it would be like this mark here but
actually we're asking if this whole
thing right because what's just the Y
right so if that is crossing our cars
top if that's the case then we might
have crossover but not necessarily right
so this we would just say we'll just say
print step 1
and what this is just going to do is
it's going to output to our consul that
you know we're finding we're saying
there's some crossover here so for
example we can run this and here is our
game and as it was going of course you
couldn't see it on mine but hopefully on
your as you can see as the Box started
to come below um here we go at this
point right as it's crossing over start
spamming out step one step with some
some right so we've got Y crossover so
we could actually change this to Y
crossover now the next thing we need to
know is if the exes are crossing over so
the question is here is if X is greater
than thing underscores start X and so if
the X is greater than this X so and then
keep in mind X is the location of our
car so let's say this is our car we're
asking if the top left of our car here
is
greater than here basically so if if X
is greater than that which basically
means if if as long as it's not like
past the car pretty much so if X is
greater than things start X and well
this one's going to be kind of a long
long links we have to ask multiple
questions but stick with me so if that's
the case um so basically if if the
object is possibly crossing if that then
if that's the case and X is less than
thing underscores start X plus thing
oops
thing thanks right plus thing underscore
wit so again the X's are the horizontal
movement basically so if this if X is
less than um the start X which is here
plus the width so that's here okay so we
have to be less than okay and then the
question is if X is less than things
start X plus thing with oh not capital
work not capital or or X plus car
underscore wit is greater than so X plus
car width so we're asking now X plus car
with is this point right here if X plus
car width is greater greater than thing
underscore start X so let me make this a
little let me make the text smaller
we're still going to go off the screen
but it'll be a little easier to see
so let's this and this down okay so and
so we've got if this and this or this um
or X plus car with square then
thing underscore star X and X plus car
underscore width is less than so this is
asking if that was greater than star X
but then we also need to know if X plus
car with is less than thing underscore
start X plus the thing with so basically
we're asking if we're within the
boundaries of this and this because we
have to be within somewhere within those
boundaries in order for this to actually
occur but as I was saying before
that's a collision fully being within
the boundaries is a collision and then
being over here would still be a
collision so you have to kind of keep
this in mind anyway if all of that is
the case um then we'll say print X cross
over and then at this point we Institute
a crash okay so let's save that and let
me just fix my window and now let's run
that and see how we do so you have a
little car first want to make sure we
can avoid and cross over like that
and it looks like we can and now let's
go ahead and have a crash okay so we
crash there easy enough let's check the
other side of a crash caught it nice so
we crash there as expected
um and try to think of any other the
other thing you just want to check like
if you were to like drive over it right
away that's kind of helpful or if you're
under it but then you get out from it
that would be another instance now the
crash I just had the problem with that
even though it doesn't look like we
crash it's because our image is 73
pixels wide because we had to make a box
around our car and that's just that
there's this again and it really would
have hit the rear tire I suppose you
could make the argument but because
we're calling our image really a square
and that's why we're actually still
having a collision here anyway so the
next thing
I guess we could we could cut it off at
this point so so now we have some boxes
to avoid and you know that's okay you
know we can keep playing that but this
this game is relatively boring it's easy
to skip the boxes generally the way a
game is made is the first few levels of
the firstly you know few seconds at
least are going to be easy it gets the
player kind of acclimated to how the
game works but then the challenge is
escalated and that's what we want to do
we want to kind of escalate the
challenge also there's really no no
tracking here like how good are we doing
like anything like that so we want to
have some sort of scoring system as well
so when a scoring system and then also
increasing the some sort of difficulty
making this more and more challenging so
that's what we're going to be doing in
the next video so if you guys have any
questions or comments on this one feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching things for
all this forth subscriptions and until
next time